the president is taking new steps to
block that caravan from entering this
country he campaigned in Missouri after
moving to limit where migrants can apply
for asylum and suggesting that border
violence could be met with gunfire he
says if they throw rocks officers should
feel okay about shooting back with
bullets the president visits West
Virginia and Indiana later today
part of an eight-state swing in the
final days of the campaign
major Garrett covered last night's rally
in Columbia and joins us with more on
that story major good morning good
morning to you the president hit the
main midterm closing argument themes
immigration tax cuts and the Supreme
Court but at times the speech just
frankly rambled at one point the
president blamed news coverage of what
he called maniacs by that he meant the
anti-semitic gunman who killed 11 at
that Pittsburgh synagogue and the
suspect now charged with sending pipe
bombs two prominent Democrats of
blunting Republican midterm political
momentum back on immigration the
president called for tighter border
security and he also offers some
exaggerated claims about the migrant
threat you know we called up the
military because we're not going to let
people come into our country when you
look at that illegally not going to
happen
President Trump told an overflow crowd
in Central Missouri he would seal the
southern border in advance of a Honduran
migrant caravan still weeks away people
have really galvanized over this we want
people to come into our country but they
have to come into our country legally
and through merit and through merit
earlier at the White House the president
said he would use executive power to
require migrants seeking asylum in the
u.s. to apply only at ports of entry not
at the border where they can apply now
we're building massive numbers of tents
and we will hold them in tents the u.s.
processed nearly three hundred and
thirty thousand asylum claims last year
almost double the number two years
earlier these migrants are not
legitimate asylum seekers according to
the Department of Homeland Security the
number of credible fear or persecution
or torture cases have also reached
record highs in recent years up by
nearly 70 percent between 2015 and 2016
the president also said active-duty
soldiers would return fire if migrants
threw rocks at them we will consider
that a firearm because there's not much
difference when you get hit in the face
with a rock in a statement the Pentagon
said it will not discuss hypothetical
situations but our forces always have
the inherent right of Defense that
Pentagon statement went on to quote
emphasize unquote that the military will
support border patrol and not
participate in any law enforcement
activities back on the president's
asylum moves critics accused him of
lying about the hardships that asylum
seekers actually face while trampling on
US law and international agreements John
Major thank you